guess what we've got some exciting news
you can now text the minimalist podcast
your questions nine three seven two oh
two four six five four we'll do our best
to answer as many of your questions as
possible but even if we don't answer
them on air we might even text you back
Ryan and I both get that text it comes
right to our phones nine three seven two
oh two four six five four enjoy the show
and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist indeed we are Ryan today
we're gonna record a podcast about
podcast I was just thinking like how
many this is really this is I brought my
podcasting voice this is our first
podcast of 2020 happy new year everyone
yeah it's just me and Ryan in the studio
along with podcast Shawn and Jordan no
more and this is really for people who
are creatives and the good news is
you're all creative in some way and so
this is for you if you're looking for
new ways to create it's not just gonna
be about podcasting we're gonna give you
so a little bit of our recipe for
podcasting if we have time we'll answer
some questions as well but also if
you're thinking about other ways to
create whether it's through artwork or
writing or blogging or maybe you want to
create your first book
maybe it's photography we really want to
speak to the creatives or the aspiring
creatives today but one of the things
that I've noticed Ryan since we've been
doing this for well this is our tenth
year now yeah we started back well 10
years ago in 2010 it's now 2020 and we
started and I just wanted to write books
mm-hm and you had an idea like well
maybe we could share this online and we
could start a blog or a website and so
we did that
but then I've become more vehicle
agnostic over the last decade we've been
out on several tours that's another way
for us to create and communicate with
people yes remember that first tour
eight people showed up with the first
tour stuff Yemen and it just grew from
there every times yeah and and what I
realized is that I really enjoy finding
new ways to create and so about four
years ago the two of us and podcast Sean
we were in Missoula Montana we've had a
little tiny conference room that was
basically a broom closet yeah and we
started recording some podcasts four
years ago mm-hmm it's actually four
years ago this week that this comes out
and so over the last four years we've
learned a whole lot about podcasting
what it takes to create
a successful podcast in fact podcast
Shawn and I wrote this long a blog post
I'm not gonna read this to you you can
find it over at the minimalists comm
slash microphone we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well but it's
called how will to start a successful
podcast I'm so glad you guys wrote that
because I cannot tell you how many
people reach out to me and they're like
what's your advice for podcasting right
and yeah so now now we're gonna have
this podcast in addition to this this
blog post right and I think it's some
really awesome material for people to
yeah to learn how to create their own
podcast if that's what they're looking
to do and what I really hope to
accomplish with this is not to
regurgitate everything that is in this
this blog post which is long in fact
we're just gonna cover the the five the
top five steps and maybe a few other
things of course it's a novella well
it's all it's all fact so yeah it does
seem like it is it's quite long but it
it's in several different sections the
first bit is very short and it's called
how to start a podcast in five steps now
Ryan I thought you and I could talk
about this and then we'll weave in other
creative aspects as well and the reason
that these five steps were really
important for us is it really simplified
the process because man it is
overwhelming mm-hmm you think about how
am I gonna host the thing and the
microphone in the room and all these
things but then the rest of the blog
post goes from pre-production to
production and post-production and and
Sean wrote that part and really went
into immense detail we're not going to
cover all of that in here but we're
gonna start with these five steps the
beginning of this blog post cool the
first thing that was really important to
us I listened to a lot of podcasts a lot
of them have questionable audio quality
sure and sometimes it's so bad or just
so mediocre it's not even bad that I it
distracts me from being able to listen
to it sure now that doesn't mean you
have to go rent an NPR studio and spend
hundreds of dollars an hour there so our
first step is purchased a quality
microphone you can get a quality
microphone for around a hundred dollars
yes I mean we use the yetis for the
longest time yeah we use that and I
think the other one in here is the rode
podcaster those are the two that we use
up put a link to that actually
is in the put a link in the show notes
as well Shawn but they are it's all here
in this blog post as well
now we've upgraded since then but here's
the thing you don't have to go all out
when you first start you don't have to
have we have these video cameras here I
think it was a hundred and forty
something episodes in before we even
started doing video and and because we
wanted to do it right and the same thing
with audio I don't think we wanted to
create something that is going to - I
mean the thing that you create will
essentially last forever or at least
your lifetime and so at first when you
and I started creating we weren't always
happy with a podcast that we created
right I remember the first few episodes
we did we would record somewhere between
four to six episodes before we published
one and that's just because we were
getting comfortable with the medium
comfortable with the format also
comfortable with the quality and the
quality really starts with getting a
good microphone a relatively inexpensive
microphone if you have a computer you
can buy one of these hundred dollar
microphones you can set it up there and
all of a sudden you have much better
quality than if you just started
recording it on an iPhone or with a
really janky microphone sure I bring
that up because although I know some
great podcasters who recorded with janky
microphones and tell me but - - but to
your point though I don't want to call
him out on this well I actually will Rob
Bell was one of them he uses his sons he
did my cell phone yeah now he uses this
mic that we're using right now yeah but
I guess what I'm getting at is is that
you can you know you can still come out
with a quality podcast but the little
details that you couldn't kind of
improve it's just gonna make your
podcast that much better so but but I
would say that like Rob's Genki mic that
is Jay key though is that one of those
hundred dollar or so it was just his
sons Mike right yeah he found it under
his bed right say I think Yeti snowball
or something like that but anyway it was
the functional equivalent right but then
like yeah then yeah but then you got
people who record it like on their
iPhone yeah and that's a little bit yeah
I recommend against that and here's why
absolutely because you don't want to
notice it in fact that's one of the nice
things about our podcast it sounds like
one of the best podcasts out there Thank
You podcast Sean for that now it's still
and simple it doesn't require a whole
lot so in that blog post we go through
well here is the purchase a a quality
microphone
we have beginner microphones and then we
have professionals so if you want to
mimic our setup this professional setup
isn't even that expensive these
microphones are what four or five
hundred bucks right you know about four
hundred bucks so so it's not crazy
I wouldn't recommend starting there
though no it's it's maybe 10 to 20
percent better quality but but here's
the thing if you're getting started get
started and make sure you like it you
can still have some of that's quality
without having to be a professional
studio yeah we did that for a long time
yeah and one thing to note too you know
the microphone you have isn't
necessarily gonna make you a better
podcaster absolutely not so you know I
know I get stuck or used to get stuck in
the trap of I'd get a new hobby or you
know whatever look into something and
I'm like oh I want to get this but I'm
gonna go ahead and spend the extra money
to get the super advanced nice version
right when in all actuality like you
just need something that is you know
that's gonna provide a good audio
experience but yeah getting a sure Mike
versus a Yeti mic that's not going to
make you a better podcast in fact it
might make you worse at first because
you're relying too heavily on the
equipment
just like when you're snowboarding Ryan
if you I'm gonna buy the $7000 snowboard
it's you're gonna fall over better now
like no you have to learn how to
actually snowboard okay well after the
microphone step 2 has purchased the
right recording equipment honestly when
we started it was just us with the the
Yeti mic the rode podcaster mics we had
2 mics Sean was in the room we hooked it
up to GarageBand on his record rental
app recorded a right to his computer
right to GarageBand that is free we have
some other programs in there now we use
something called a zoom h6 still
relatively primitive it's not one of
those giant recording boards you would
see right at a studio sean is manning
the the h6 right now he pots up and down
to gain and and I think you could put
what six different inputs in that's why
it's called an h6 for my up to four
microphones or I am and so you can
decide whether or not you want to have
guests and we'll talk about format and
all of these other things
well I feel like I feel like the h6
versus Garageband
I don't hear Shawn complaining about as
many problems with the age six where his
GarageBand there was just a couple
little I don't know glitches that would
happen it would glitch more right who
are the recording itself right but then
of course the next step is choose an
editing program and we still use
GarageBand for editing it is great for
what we're trying to accomplish by we we
mean podcast Sean right okay you know I
mean in fact he's using it right now as
a backup as well right so in case
something were to happen I think this is
happening only once where a file gets
corrupted or something on the h6 he at
least has a backup so we don't lose what
we have here and he writes about that in
here having some redundancy or some
backup so you don't lose things that
you've recorded number four out of the
five steps is fine and inexpensive
hosting platform you can put your
podcast up for free on soundcloud in
fact we still do that
so soundcloud.com slash the minimalists
it's a great platform in the app you can
have on a smartphone or whatever so if
you want to get started for absolute
free that's the way to do it if you want
to make sure your podcast is on Apple
podcasts and overcast and Google
podcasts and Spotify and all these other
places then you need a good host we use
a company called Lipson which is short
for liberal what is it liberated
syndicate right I'll put a link to that
in in the show notes as well but you can
use whoever you want that's who we've
used since the very beginning we do have
a small affiliate relationship with them
so if you I think we can get a free
month of hosting if you want to try them
out I don't know the details there's
somewhere in that blog post but you can
use whoever you want that's just who we
views we only recommend places and in
products obviously that we've used
personally and whether or not they work
for you is really up to you and how you
use them step 5 the most important step
Ryan you alluded to this a moment ago
like you can buy all the great equipment
you can have the right editing program I
found the perfect host and then what do
you do now you well you actually have to
make the thing that you've wanted to
make yeah and and you got to put it out
into the world
yes yeah you have to record and upload
your first podcast that is that is
really step 5 sometimes that's the
hardest part man like putting yourself
out there cuz you know people are gonna
listen to it they're gonna they're gonna
judge you a little bit or you know maybe
they'll provide some feedback for you
but it's funny when I think about well
this is with anything we've created Josh
tell me our very first book or a very
first podcast like I except for
minimalism or documentary very first
documentary that is gorgeous and I look
at that and I'm like this is the most
beautiful thing we've ever created
alright so besides that everything else
that we've all the other vehicles we've
used I look back at those early works
uh-huh and I'm like oh like I've grown
so much since then yeah and that's a
good thing though and even since the
documentary obviously we've grown
immensely we're working on our second
film in fact we can talk about this
right now
we just finished and by the time this
episode comes out we should be done
completely with production of our second
film which is called blesses now and
it'll be out sometime in 2020 on Netflix
stay tuned for more details on that make
sure you're on our email list if you
want to be the first to hear about that
and check out some behind the scenes
stuff now Ryan what I have here from the
blog post three reasons you should start
a podcast and three reasons you should
not start a podcast and I think
unfortunately too often we swap these
two things right so the three reasons
you should number one is value adding
value to other people's lives is the
primary goal and any endeavor that we do
any creative endeavor yeah and we're
always asking that even if we're gonna
send a tweet will this tweet add value
will this blog post add value well this
book I'm writing add value will this
podcast episode add value if not I don't
want to clutter the world with more
noise and so think about that when you
are creating your podcast or whatever
else you're creating will this add value
number two is experience now you don't
have experience yet there's only one way
to get it though mmm-hmm actually do it
yeah podcasting will give you an Evelyn
valuable experience in several areas
writing speaking performing audio
recording editing and distribution
website development graphic
design promotion etc and by the way we
talked about how to create cover art and
all that other stuff in this blog post
as well but that's not really ideal for
the audio format that we have here but
so in the blog post tells you about
cover art and how to get your podcast
onto all these different platforms as
well third and finally why you should
start a podcast and I think this one has
been really important for us especially
as our podcast has changed over the last
four years Ryan especially it's become
more guest heavy recently we've
developed a format and aesthetic our
podcast is a listener driven show
usually people call in and we answer
their questions a lot like Dan Savage
or Dave Ramsey and or you know you think
I like talk radio a people will call
them we have conversations it's very
similar to that but we've also
incorporated guests recently and that is
a deliberate decision and so we ask you
some questions throughout this blog post
about how to start a successful blog
about your format because here's one
thing that I've learned Ryan people
really like consistency yeah they don't
want the the minimalist podcast to be
one way one week and then we do
something completely different where
we're like oh we're going to a petting
zoo this week with the minimalist
podcast like it wouldn't make sense so
there's a particular format we answer
people's questions and now we answer
people with questions but with a guest
quite often hmm usually most episodes in
fact have a guest
so third is connection podcasting will
not only allow you to share your unique
perspective with a worldwide audience
but it will also give you the
opportunity to share your diverse
viewpoints with your contemporaries and
that's the thing I've grown so much
since we've started bringing guests on
and our audience has benefited from it
as well and it doesn't always work out
great and sometimes we will have a guest
in here and on paper it should work out
really well but for whatever reason it
doesn't it doesn't work maybe I'm not
jiving with the person you're not or or
the they're not answering the questions
in the way that I would expect now part
of that just expectations but what I've
learned is that as we're interacting
with these people man I
there's this old adage the the teacher
learns more than the student and I feel
like especially since we started this
podcast I've learned a lot more about
myself about how to interact about how
to answer questions in a way that we
wouldn't have before this right yeah so
connection it has been really big for us
now here are three reasons you should
not start a podcast number one is money
yeah
if money is your primary driver for
starting a podcast you'll likely find
yourself horribly disappointed mmm you
know Ryan there are 800,000 podcasts out
there right now well and many of them
want to start because they want to make
money or whatever in fact I remember the
gal I think was that our doubtless event
and she said well I have a blog and I'm
not like you guys I have to I have to
have ads on my my blog and you have to
really
why do you say yeah well I have to make
money okay maybe you do have to make
money but maybe you don't have to do it
through I imagine the the CMO and at
Marlboro also says well you got to do
what you got to do to make money sure it
may be it doesn't align with your values
for me advertising doesn't align with
our values now it's not to say we can't
make money from this podcast we have a
patreon and and thankfully we have
almost 5,000 patrons at this point and I
think we're capping a 6,000 patrons so
that's a way for us to pay for the
studio space to pay Sean and Jess and
Jordan but money is not the primary
driver for doing what we do
Sean wrote this when we produce
creations based on chasing the dragon of
money the creations are often Hollow
yeah and they fail to resonate deeply
with a wide loyal audience that said
there's nothing wrong with earning money
from your podcasts we just don't want
the almighty dollar to be the reason we
create it's also a good way to kill a
passion - yes like if you're relying on
you know doing your passion at work to
make money well then now you're relying
on oh well I got it I have to create in
order to pay my bills and you know you
want it to be a get to as much as
possible not
have to yeah so money can certainly
change it from a get to to a half to
another one I've noticed Ryan number two
is on this why you shouldn't start a
podcast is fame yeah
now Fame like money is an incredibly
loose is incredibly elusive and often
empty quote reward you're more likely to
find your creativity and your pursuit
starve to death if you're planting seeds
in this barren field instead aim to
provide value to an audience and what it
which is a much more noble pursuit
that's the thing I mean Fame is a very
empty vapid Ryan you I've sort of become
we're not famous we've become
accidentally recognizable or infamous
wait a minute not yet but there's a
certain amount of people who appreciate
our work but it's being well-known for
the right thing yes it's not being
celebrated for the fact that we have
notoriety that's that's empty as as Sean
wrote here and then finally promotion
creating a podcast simply to promote a
product or service will often have the
opposite effect people have an acute
radar for detecting in all in all thin
to City and once they have they avoid
the offending source like the plague I
mean I think that's true like all these
brands don't try to be a brand that's
just it's disgusting mmm-hmm like okay
you can call the minimalist a brand if
you want but Ryan you and I are never
talking hey how does that affect our
brand image yeah I mean it you can
create a brand but if you do it in a
disingenuous way well then it comes
across as disingenuous i I think that's
the thing I I think trying to create a
brand often comes up the brand that
we've created if you even call it that
is something that has been organic it's
just like hey well it's well we're the
minimalist because we want to get the
minimalists calm and so we got that and
but we're also you're the face of the
minimalist but the minimum us are us and
and Sean and Jeff and Dave and and
Jordan and Jess and
everyone who listens to this or everyone
who reads it's part of the minimalist
like it's it's a bit of a double
entendre there it's anyone who wants to
be part of of this community right yeah
but I mean I think the brand that we
have it just comes from being consistent
and being ourselves because like you can
look at the minimalists logo like
there's a logo there and right sure but
yeah it's not but we don't do it for the
sake of like you said for the brand
we're not sitting there around you know
having a meeting like okay how can we
how can we make our brand stronger this
month right yeah right and so creating
something just to promote your product
or service like you and I talk about
products and services sometimes that we
find value in or things that we've
created but it's not the primary driver
for doing what we do it's the same as
money and certainly the same thing for
fame and I'm definitely doing this to
try to get famous these are all
byproducts they're not the drivers
exactly it's a great way to put it and
so I would encourage you to take a look
at that blog post if you want to create
your own podcast it is a great place to
get started all of the details
everything from cover art to uploading
to editing to production all the notes
and even starting a website or blog to
publish your show notes the email list
all of these things are covered in there
we have a few questions and so let's try
to get through these relatively quickly
the first one here is from Amanda in
Nashville my question for you is I would
want to know what you would recommend to
someone who wants to become a mentor I
got my degree in psychology and I
figured formal education was my only
escape from the economic situation I was
born into and while I love the education
I received and I really want to learn
more I regret the significant amount of
debt I've gotten into as a result trying
to work really hard to get rid of that I
am working a full time and a part-time
job to make up for it and neither of
which are bringing me much value to my
life I want to eventually become a
licensed Marriage and Family counselor
and to get my master's in that but I
know I can't afford it anytime soon I've
been reaching out to people to try and
help them for as long as I can remember
and I'd like to find a way to maybe
organize it to become more accessible
more people and maybe support myself in
the process so what would you recommend
for someone who's trying to start out in
mentorship Ryan your mentor yes I am a
mentor well you know it's funny I didn't
like ever think I was going to be a
mentor or I'd like have a mentoring side
hustle basically where my mentoring came
from and you're kind of a mentor too in
a way when it comes to your writing
classes yeah yeah yeah I consider myself
a teacher but yeah that makes I yeah its
semantics I call my mentee student so
you guys so yeah I mean I guess I would
yeah I'm a life coach so I don't know
why but every time I say life coach like
it just because it has such a negative
connotation now well then here's this is
a perfect perfect segue into Amanda's
question here right I think life most
life coaches don't have much life
experience yeah and this is the first
place where Amanda needs to start great
you've gone through college you you
you've gotten some education oh by the
way don't confuse schooling with
education right amanda says she really
wants to learn more great there are
plenty of ways for you to learn without
having to pay for additional schooling
you you can still get an education
whether it's watching MIT lectures on
YouTube it's just going to your local
college and in auditing classes you can
often do that for free there are meetup
groups there are Skillshare websites and
all of these different places that you
don't have to spend or you can spend a
little bit of money not go tens of
thousands of dollars into debt and get a
good education without the schooling now
she wants to be a mentor Ryan the thing
that I that I want to caution her
against is you need some life experience
before you can't be a mint that's a
great point man I think about the
therapists I have right now which I
guess maybe he he's like my friend
therapists slash mentor he's not a
licensed therapist like he's just he's
someone who has a lot of life experience
that I trust and I would much rather
talk to him who has life experience than
someone who just like went through all
the schooling but hasn't actually lived
hasn't lived their life the way that you
know someone I don't know if someone
could you can speak better to your life
experience than what a book is going to
tell you yeah
you have the life experience to to be a
mentor I'm so at you and I both you we
both grew up poor so you have you have
that that experience right a lot of drug
and alcohol abuse and our families right
now you also had some substance abuse in
your own life so you have that point of
view that you're able to to provide to
other people and also in overcoming that
now also you went from being poor to
being quote/unquote successful in the
traditional sense you climb the
corporate ladder so you have that
experience you manage large teams or
small teams of people and then you
manage large teams of people you focus
on sales and marketing so you have that
experience
you ran retail stores you have that
experience you did business-to-business
sales that's life experience that you
have flow and then you have some of the
most remarkable experience you got laid
off from your job that is an experience
right you had to go through these
experiences you can't just read about
them right in order to convey that
information the reading helps it helps
round it out yeah absolutely but you
have the experience and then oh you have
the experience of building a business or
several businesses now that we have a
coffee shop down in st. Petersburg so
you have different business experience
as well now all those things are so much
better than the the bachelors of
business management degree that you have
right yeah it's great that you have that
degree and that maybe that's a checkbox
but there are so many other boxes that
are so much more relevant when it comes
to being a mentor and it's that life
experience that you have and and now the
experience that you have the reason
you're able to talk about podcasting
because you've been doing it for four
years right the thing the reason you
could talk about blogging is you've been
doing it for 10 years you could talk
about social media because you've been
you're not an influencer and better than
an influencer you are influential mm-hmm
and I think there's a substantial
difference between the two yeah and so
if I'm gonna give a man to any advice
it's three things get some real-world
experience you know number two start a
podcast and you don't even have to
necessarily publish it but it's going to
because what are we doing here Ron we
are being mentors on this podcast it's a
mentorship program
for us in a way yeah I would encourage
you to start a podcast and I don't not
saying keep doing forever do six
episodes and if something that interests
you find a format and make it a project
and the other thing is start a blog you
know and write whether it's once a week
once every day or once a month and what
what writing is going to do is gonna
help you solidify your thoughts it's
gonna help you better understand how you
think and how you can communicate and
express yourself to other yeah what I
hear you recommending to Amanda here is
find some vehicles that you feel
comfortable using to get your message
out there because that's the one thing
about being a mentor is you have to be
an expert in some way or fashion so you
get that through life experience and
then you express that life experience
through whatever vehicle it is blogging
podcasting YouTube videos which I guess
is just a vlog but yeah you could do
whatever you want Amanda but yes you I
would also totally yeah just echo what
Josh said find a way to get your message
out there whether it's yeah podcasting
or whether it's starting a blog but and
those are all ways to gain experience
right yeah so for yeah so for me the
reason why I even started a mentoring
business was because people kept sending
me like ten thousand word emails hey
here's my situation
I really respect what you do here's here
are my thoughts what would you do if you
were me and I was like oh like I'm
getting a lot of these emails I could
probably start to be a mentor and charge
for it and make a little money from it
while helping people and you know what
if you're adding value to people's lives
they're willing to compensate you for it
right so so Amanda you know find a way
to add value to people's lives through
mentoring and you absolutely will find
people who will compensate you for your
time
I don't think I really have anything
else for her Amanda and I'm gonna send
you a copy of our book everything that
remains it's really the story of of our
experience like our experiences growing
up poor our experiences making it in the
business world and then leaving the
business world our experiences there as
well and so all the experiences we've
gained over the first well that book
came out well it was finished when we
were 32 years old so it's 32 years worth
of experience and I think you'll find
some value in our experience if you like
our podcast I think you're
really enjoy the audiobook version of
everything that remains by the way it's
my favorite thing that we've ever
created or if you want the book book or
the eBook version be happy to send those
to you as well
we're running out of time so I'm gonna
save Maddie from Columbus Ohio I'm gonna
save her question for the maximal Ryan
what time is a Sun for lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media indeed we do we are at the
minimalists on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram now this is the lightning
round where we we try to answer your
questions with just a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media and now
you can find all of our pithy answers in
one place thanks to Jessica social Jess
that place is minimal Maxim's calm all
right our question is from kr earlier
this month I left my corporate job after
two years of planning to start a
wellness business I got certified two
years ago and spent this past year
writing a book which is now out for beta
reader feedback while I go through the
self-publishing process I'm looking to
begin the next project how do I decide
among the many options create an online
course develop a workshop focused on my
blog explore podcasting pursue one on
one coaching something else yeah this is
a man her question stresses me out a
little bit
so here's here's my pithy answer I have
three of them actually so I'm gonna read
the second one first Erin you can do
everything but not at the same time yeah
and and what I mean by that is over the
last decade yeah oh and I did the blog
we've done three books for working on
our fourth one now we've done nine tours
in nine years we have done two hundred
and fourteen podcast episodes now
actually it's much more than that
because although the patreon episodes
which are even longer than these and so
we have hundreds of podcast episodes but
you eat the elephant one bite at a time
yeah I mean we didn't start out and
we're like okay we're the minimalists
we've got this website now now we got to
you know check all these boxes with the
blog with a podcast with the documentary
with books and yeah if we looked at the
whole elephant instead of taking it one
piece at a time then yes we absolutely
well I don't think we'd be as I don't
know we wouldn't have had as many
creations as we do now but kind of
taking it one at a time it has really
helped us to use many many vehicles and
create a lot of things be focused really
nice thing because if we were to put all
right Ryan we're gonna work on these ten
projects you put them all on the table
what happens you put ten percent into
each of them mm-hmm well ten percent
doesn't get you very far that's an F -
yeah and so so if you try to work on
them all right now kr you're going to
fail any of those things that you pick
which them what's the one that excites
you when you get up in the morning
you're like I really really really want
to do that is it a book is it an online
course is it a workshop is a one-on-one
coaching is it podcasting whatever that
is the thing that excites you start with
that yeah and once you've mastered that
you can always move on to the next thing
Ryan and I work on one major project a
year and then everything else we do
serves that project yeah I would be
careful too
kr to not pick the project that you
think is gonna make you the most money
so kind of going back to what we were
talking to at the beginning of this
podcast if you're if you're gonna pick a
pop project because you're like oh this
is money I can make this is gonna give
me Fame like if you're doing it for the
wrong reasons or I'm sorry if you're
doing it for those reasons those are the
wrong reasons and ultimately you're
choosing the wrong thing and Dean I got
a few more pithy answers for you we
could put these in the show notes it's
one of my favorites create value not
content man that's the other thing to
think about we don't want to be content
creators we don't want to add to the
noise we want to make things they're
gonna stand the test of time they're
gonna last the rest of your lifetime
things that you'll be really happy with
a decade from now not because they're
perfect I don't want you to be a
perfectionist but I want you to be
really proud of the yes given the
resources I have this is the absolute
best I could do and knowing that you can
always improve upon it in the future
you're gonna continue to be a better
writer or coach or podcaster or whatever
but you're gonna be really satisfied
with the work that you put into it and
finally Ryan
my my third pithy answer is if you don't
know what you want you'll get everything
you don't want ain't that the truth
my pithy answer is this good businesses
make money great businesses solve
problems I mean you've got to ask
yourself how are you gonna help people
solve problems K are like and that is
how you choose which project you you
pick like what are you passionate about
what gets you excited and let's say
you've got four projects and you're like
oh but I really am excited about these
four things then look at the one that's
gonna help the most people solve the
most problems and that is how you're
gonna pick pick the best thing to work
on can I pinned your pithy answer
because I love no I love right go ahead
so so can you read the first half of
that again what is it good good
businesses make money good businesses
make money
great businesses make a difference yeah
oh good women there we go nice so you
got to to work with their podcast Sean
all right before we get into our added
value segment and our listener tips
today it looks like we had a bunch more
surprise questions this week how do you
develop the discipline to consistently
produce new creations
how can minimalism feed creativity how
do you deal with writer's block
I've got a controversial answer on that
one Ryan what's the ideal creative
environment to keep you focused while
creating how can I create engaging
Instagram and Facebook posts I love this
one Ryan
I'm very busy how could I find the time
for creating that's imagine personal I
typed it out and they were panicked what
are some misconceptions about creativity
and how would you de bunk them and we
got a bunch of more questions we're
going to talk about today and if you
want to hear all that listen to this
week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about
topics we don't usually discuss in
public plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast and keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast
find all the details and all the good
stuff over at the minimalists comm slash
support Ryan Welsh you got for us this
week here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hi Josh and
Ryan my name is Zeile from Jersey City
New Jersey in regards to episode 204 as
an artist I find it helpful to add my
own expiration dates on my supplies so I
can use them within a month or a year
this helps me set a date usually with a
permanent marker on the packaging or on
a post-it note hey guys this is Jessica
calling from Boston about episode 190 on
positive thinking you guys were
discussing whether or not it's a good
idea to try and be positive all the time
even on your bad days faking it til you
make it
etc and I definitely think it's a
strength and a skill to be able to look
on the positive side of things but at
the same time I think it's really
important to dig deep and figure out the
why and everything that comes up in our
lives whether it's good or bad after
discovering that we have like 60,000
thoughts a day and about how 80% of them
can be negative and self-critical I
thought that especially on the really
bad days where that percentage might be
a little bit higher it might be
beneficial to actually just minimize the
total amount of thoughts that you have
instead of using your energy to try to
be positive all day which can get quite
draining actually so I started to
implement this really cool two-step
process on the days where I just can't
seem to be positive at all and it's
really been helping me out a lot so step
one is I try to just spend my entire day
being in a constant state of awareness
and meditation so I'm just absorbing
paying attention I don't give any
prolonged thought to anything at all I'm
not judging and I do this whether I'm at
home all day I'm going to work or
hanging out with friends whatever it is
I just try to stay in the moment and
then whenever any negative thoughts try
to creep back up I remind myself to get
back to that state so overall this
limits the amount of total thoughts I
have throughout the day which then
limits the amount of negativity I end up
spending my focus on right and it gives
me kind of like a mental break and then
step two is
hopefully the next day when I wake up
I'm feeling better I take some time to
reflect in journal so the idea is not to
ignore your bad feelings which can get
quite dangerous and destructive over
time but you wait for a better day when
they feel less overwhelming and
crippling so that you can process them
this just seems like a really healthy
way to love and be genuine to myself and
I hope that this helps some of the
listeners who maybe don't do well when
it comes to putting that smile on on
those tough days alright y'all real
quick four right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist speaking of creativity
writing is my preferred platform but my
preferred means my preferred medium of
communication and expression I like all
of these others including what we're
doing right now podcasting but writing
is the thing that I'm most passionate
about and if you want to learn how to
improve your writing how to write better
well I teach a writing class an online
writing class and we're getting ready to
open up a hundred seats this or later
this quarter and if you were interested
in that we only open it up for one or
two days at a time and last time we did
it last quarter it sold out pretty
quickly it's called how to write better
and you can find details that how to
write better org just enter your email
address over there if you want to be
notified when the next class is opened
up if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm you'll also receive our
simple Sunday emails and for our added
value this week Ryan I'm gonna recommend
we run River North they come out with a
new album they came out with a new EP
okay it is really good it's called
monsters calling home vol 2 and my
favorite song from that is a song called
wave they opened up our Los Angeles show
a couple years ago when Rob was with us
yeah Rob Bell did a show with us they
opened up it was unbelievable is that
the Belasco downtown Los Angeles one of
my favorite bands their music just
sounds like Los Angeles
to me yeah there's something about and
this new EP is really good
check out wave from monsters calling
home and if you leave here today with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus